odds are you are surrounded by
nose-pickers it's true one study found
that 91 percent of adults admitted to
picking their nose regularly so chances
are you've probably mined for some juicy
nose nuggets yourself but maybe you
didn't stop there maybe you ate those
boogers too and it turns out that slimy
snack could hurt more than just your
social standing let's take a closer look
at that booger shall we it's mostly made
out of water gel like proteins that give
it that gooey consistency and special
immune proteins that fight off germs
those immune proteins are especially
useful because boogers are teeming with
harmful viruses like influenza and
actually that's the whole point
boogers serve is your body's frontline
defense against invading germs when you
breathe in you're not just inhaling air
you're also taking in bacteria viruses
and dirt all those nasty things get
trapped by a layer of sticky snot that
line your nostrils
it's like flypaper for the flu and as
you continue to breathe air hardens
mucus into a solid booger a gooey prison
cell for all your ensnared enemies now
normally you can get rid of that
bacteria ridden ball either when you
sneeze or blow your nose but if you for
some reason decide to eat it instead it
stands to reason that you're putting
yourself at risk of infection because as
your body digests the booger it can
release those harmful pathogens into
your system now some people claim that
eating your boogers can strengthen your
immune system by training your body to
recognize and attack invading microbes
but sorry to say there is ZERO
scientific evidence to support any
health benefits from eating your boogers
zero zilch and besides whether or not
you decide to eat them just getting a
hold of your boogers can
be dangerous for example scratching up
the inside of your nose opens the door
for a nasty bacteria that lurks under
your fingernails Staphylococcus aureus
or staff a 2006 study found that nose
Pickers were more likely to have staff
in their nose than those who abstain and
that's a big problem since staff can
cause serious abscesses or pus-filled
pockets inside your nose and on your
face even worse if you keep picking you
could actually puncture your septum
in one case a 53 year old woman managed
to carve a hole right through her sinus
and if that sinus becomes infected badly
enough it can erode your skull leaving
the door open for bacteria to march
right into your brain but to be fair
these are extreme scenarios one time
probably won't hurt you but when it
comes down to it next time you feel the
urge to mine for green gold just grab a
tissue man